Si os pregunto por Suiza, seguro, seguro que
muchos automáticamente pensáis en bancos,
joyas y cajas fuertes. La reina de los
paraísos fiscales. El país dónde el dinero
nunca duerme. El sitio donde la cuenta bancaria
es muuucho más importante que la propia comida.
¿Me equivoco? Seguro que no.
Y eso que últimamente las cosas han cambiado
mucho. Sí, sí, Suiza ya no es lo que era.
Para poder acceder al mercado común, la
Confederación Helvética ha tenido que hacer
un montón de concesiones. Por ejemplo,
modificar por completo la legislación
sobre el secreto bancario. Reformas que,
lógicamente, han tenido consecuencias.
(Suiza ha ido progresivamente perdiendo
posiciones en algunos de los rankings que
nos sirven para determinar el grado
de libertad económica de un país.
Sí, Suiza sigue teniendo impuestos muy
bajos y sigue siendo el segundo país
del mundo en libertad económica según
el ranking de la Heritage Foundation,
pero si nos fijamos en las regulaciones,
ya no resulta un destino tan “paradisiaco”.
De hecho, el país ha ido cayendo progresivamente
en el ranking Doing Business del Banco Mundial,
hasta alcanzar el puesto 36 que ocupa
actualmente. Por poneros en contexto,
estaba en el puesto 19 en el año 2008.)
A ver, no nos equivoquemos.
Los suizos siguen teniendo - y
ofreciéndole al mundo - una de las mejores redes
de seguridad jurídica del para las inversiones,
el ahorro o simplemente para depositar LAS
riquezas. Y no solo hablamos de dinero.
Es decir, Suiza es un paraíso del esquí,
una potencia industrial y un importante
centro tecnológico, pero, sobre todo,
es una gigantesca caja fuerte: dinero, obras
de arte, joyas… Prácticamente de todo. Sin ir
más lejos aquí en VisualPolitik hicimos un
vídeo sobre Suiza y la industria del arte.
Y desde luego, todo el mundo se
fía del Franco Suizo, en nuestro
canal hermano VisualEconomik
ya os hemos contado el porqué.
Sin embargo, como ya os hemos dicho,
en los últimos años han cambiado muchas
cosas. No solo porque Suiza ya no sea
exactamente el país que todos imaginamos,
sino porque también le ha surgido competencia.
Hoy en el mundo ya hay países que pueden presumir,
incluso, de estar recortándole terreno
en la actividad favorita de los suizos:
ser el centro de encuentro de millonarios
y multimillonarios de todo el mundo.
De hecho, podemos encontrar un país que no solo
ya supera a Suiza en muchos campos financieros,
sino que además gracias a su localización
geográfica podría llegar a convertirse
en el nuevo refugio de las
mayores fortunas del mundo.
¿Alguna idea de qué país estamos
hablando? 3, 2, 1… ¡Exacto! Singapur
Aunque solo sea por la miniatura seguro, seguro,
que muchos lo habéis adivinado. Pues bien, fijaos.
(La plaza financiera suiza se enfrenta a
una creciente presión mundial. Hong Kong
"probablemente" superará a Suiza, "poniendo
fin a una racha de más de 200 años de dominio
suizo" en el sector de gestión de patrimonio
privado transfronterizo, dijo BCG. Asimismo,
Singapur podría desbancar a Suiza del segundo
puesto en los próximos años. - Swissinfo)
Sí, lo sé, la noticia destaca sobre
todo a Hong Kong, pero eso tiene un
poco de trampa. Hong Kong es una
importantísima plaza financiera…
Especializada sobre todo en China.
Es decir, su posición tiene mucho
que ver con ser la puerta financiera de
entrada y salidas al gigante asiático.
El caso es que Suiza ha sido un
refugio para el patrimonio de las
grandes fortunas europeas y buena
parte de las occidentales durante
aproximadamente de dos siglos,
coincidiendo con la época en la
que Occidente era el único espacio realmente
rico, pujante y próspero de todo el planeta.
Pues bien, desde hace tiempo Singapur se
está convirtiendo en algo muy pero que
muy parecido en Asia: un entorno de negocios,
ahorro e inversión abierto, seguro y sólido.
Y, ojo, que no solo hablamos de China y las
grandes fortunas de este país, sino también
de economías con expectativas asombrosas
para las próximas décadas como Indonesia,
Malasia o Vietnam. Todas ellas están a un
palmo de distancia de esta ciudad-estado.
Y por si fuera poco, pesos pesados ya
consolidados como Japón o Corea del Sur,
además de China, también
están relativamente cerca.
Por tanto, la pregunta es, ¿podríamos decir
que esta peculiar ciudad-estado del Sudeste
Asiático está llamada a convertirse en la nueva
Suiza? ¿De dónde procede toda la riqueza que
entra en Singapur y cuáles son exactamente
los motivos por los que eligen este lugar?
Pues bien, estas preguntas y más os
las vamos a contestar en este vídeo,
así que, sin más preámbulo, arranquemos.
[Por cierto, solo un último apunte… Todavía está
en construcción y aún nos quedan muchos ladrillos
por poner, pero NotNews, el nuevo miembro de la
familia VisualPolitik, ya está en circulación.
Si todavía no lo conoces, suscríbete, en
NotNews.com. Es completamente gratuito.
De momento hemos comenzado con una newsletter
pero hay mucho más por venir. ¿Nos acompañas?]
T1 (EL GUARDIÁN DE LOS DINEROS)
Suiza sigue siendo el mayor refugio de la riqueza
mundial. Según Deloitte, en 2020 la industria
financiera de este país gestionó 2,6 billones, con
B hispanos, de dólares en activos internacionales.
En total, sus activos financieros superaron
en 2021 los 4,1 billones de dólares. Para que
os hagáis una idea, esto supone casi un 40%
más que todo el tamaño del sistema financiero
de un país como España, cuya población es
5 veces y media más grande que la Suiza.
Pues bien, Singapur, aún está
a mucha distancia, en total,
según el Banco Internacional de Pagos de
Basilea, su sistema financiero gestiona
algo más de 2 billones de dólares en activos,
aproximadamente la mitad que el sistema suizo,
pero eso sí crece mucho más. Singapur se está
convirtiendo a toda velocidad en un importantísimo
centro de la gestión de patrimonios en Asia
y amenaza con superar muy pronto a Hong Kong.
Os lo hemos contado en varias
ocasiones aquí en VisualPolitik,
el asalto de Xi Jinping a Hong Kong,
tradicionalmente el epicentro, el corazón
financiero de Asia, ha dejado a la excolonia
británica con perspectivas muy poco halagüeñas
Ya sabéis, al final, la seguridad jurídica que
existía antes de que las autoridades chinas dieran
el golpe en la mesa, se saltaran los acuerdos
alcanzados y tomaran la ciudad, ya no existe,
o al menos, está desapareciendo
a toda velocidad… Evidentemente,
eso es algo que ahuyenta a los capitales
y a los inversores internacionales.
¿Tener tu dinero bajo el control de la
República Popular China de Xi Jinping?
¿Te fiarías de que nunca te metan
la mano? Evidentemente… No gracias.
Esto es algo que afecta a los inversores
internacionales… Pero también a los grandes
patrimonios que hasta ahora han utilizado
Hong Kong como una vía de escape, como una
caja fuerte fuera del alcance del Partido
Comunista Chino. Por lo que pudiera pasar.
Pero como eso ya no es posible… O en el mejor
de los casos no está del todo garantizado,
toca buscar refugio en otra parte.
¿Y sabéis qué? Este es exactamente el motivo
por el que la industria financiera de esta
ciudad-estado está teniendo una segunda
juventud. Todo apunta a que en pocos
años Singapur no solo superará a Hong
Kong como principal plaza financiera,
sino que será al continente asiático lo
que Suiza es al resto del mundo. Fijaos.
(Según Deloitte, el volumen del mercado
internacional de Hong Kong, es decir,
el número de transacciones de acciones,
depósitos, índices u otras inversiones,
creció más rápido que el de
Singapur entre 2010 y 2016.
Sin embargo, luego la cosa comenzó a
cambiar y a partir de ese último año
cayó por debajo del crecimiento de Singapur entre
2017 y 2020. Y la previsión es que
las cosas no hagan más que empeorar.
Sí, el sector financiero de Hong Kong
todavía crece, pero su dinamismo ya no
es el mismo. Mientras tanto,
Singapur no para de crecer.)
Ahora bien, las inversiones financieras no son
lo único en lo que Singapur
está despegando. Para nada.
También están llegando enormes
cantidades de dinero extranjero
en forma de inversiones directas, como
por ejemplo, la compra de inmuebles.
Y, por supuesto, como ya lo estaréis imaginando,
uno de los mayores actores en todo este
proceso están siendo los capitales chinos.
La pandemia aceleró este proceso, pero
hablamos de una tendencia de fondo…
(Según Financial Times, el número de family
offices, - esto es, fondos o plataformas de
inversión dedicadas a gestionar los grandes
patrimonios de familias concretas -, ha crecido
en Singapur un 1.400 % entre 2018 y finales
de 2021. Se ha pasado de unas 50 a más de 700.
Y se calcula que para finales de 2022 esa cifra
podía estar en torno a las 1.500. De todas ellas,
el 40 % tendrían su origen en capitales
procedentes de la China continental.
De la misma forma, tan, solo en 2022 se
registraron unas 500 empresas chinas en
Singapur. Desde allí dirigirán las
inversiones en países como la India,
y otros tantos lugares pujantes de la región.)
Y si alguien creía que con el fin de la política
COVID-zero en China las cosas se iban a calmar,
todo apunta a que lo que está
sucediendo es justo lo contrario.
(27 febrero 2023: A medida que China reabre,
la huida de chinos ricos a Singapur se
acelerará - The Wall Street Journal)
Y es que, fijaos, según la consultora Henley
& Partners, que asesora a grandes patrimonios
a obtener residencias en el extranjero, Singapur
recibió alrededor de 2.800 nuevos ricos en 2022,
convirtiéndose así en el tercer destino más
popular tras Emiratos Árabes y Australia.
[Como apunte, Suiza ocupa la quinta plaza en este
ranking con 2.200 llegadas de ricos extranjeros.]
Y aunque Singapur no publica la
nacionalidad de los nuevos residentes,
se estima que la mayor parte de
ellos son, precisamente, chinos.
Es decir, muchos chinos adinerados
le han visto las orejas al lobo
durante el COVID y ahora que se pueden mover
libremente están apostando por huir. Y sí,
el lobo es Xi Jinping, por si
es lo que estabais pensando.
Además, muchas de estas grandes fortunas chinas
temen que la tolerancia de Pekín a la hora de
dejar salir a grandes capitales y empresas pueda
terminarse… Puede, incluso, que comiencen a
restringir esos movimientos, así que muchos creen
que si no lo hacen ahora, puede que no nunca
puedan poner a buen recaudo su riqueza.
(“Esto es representativo de las políticas de la
COVID, y de las limitaciones del Partido Comunista
Chino a la vida y la libertad de las personas.
[...] Entonces, en preparación para lo peor, deben
crear una red de seguridad en el extranjero". -
Joseph Fan, profesor especializado en finanzas
y gobernanza en la Universidad de Queensland)
Además, otro de los principales motivos
por los que la elección de muchas grandes
fortunas está siendo Singapur tiene que
ver con la invasión rusa de Ucrania.
Sí, sí, me habéis oído bien, con Ucrania.
¿Y qué demonios tiene que ver Ucrania
con Singapur? Pues veréis, … Me explico,
la desconfianza hacia la visión cada vez más
nacionalista de Xi Jinping genera miedo y dudas
sobre que finalmente termine llevando
a cabo alguna acción grave en Taiwán,
lo que podría empujar a Occidente
a imponer sanciones contra China.
Por eso, muchos chinos están optando por
sitios que podrían ser más neutrales en
lugar de llevar sus riquezas a Europa o Estados
Unidos, y Singapur reúne todos esos requisitos.
El caso es que obviamente todo esto
que os estamos contando también
tiene consecuencias a nivel local.
Por ejemplo, los precios de la vivienda
en Singapur crecieron un 8,6% solo en
2022 y según analistas del mercado,
los compradores chinos fueron los que
más condominios compraron de entre
todos los compradores extranjeros.
Y es que, claro, al final,
hablamos de un microestado
de apenas 5,6 millones de habitantes en
un área poco más grande que la ciudad
de Madrid y en la que casi la mitad
son montañas o espacios protegidos.
Con lo que como imaginaréis no es tan fácil como
simplemente ponerse a construir más y
más para adaptarse a la enorme demanda.
Aunque no vamos a entrar en mucho en detalles
sobre esta cuestión porque sobre el problema de la
vivienda en Singapur ya os hablamos en un pasado
vídeo que os dejamos aquí abajo en la descripción.
Ahora bien, al margen de esta cuestión, ¿qué
está ofreciendo exactamente Singapur a los chinos
para que de repente tantos estén optando por
refugiarse allí del creciente autoritarismo de Xi?
(Pues veréis, esta ciudad-estado es
particularmente atractiva para los chinos.
Está cerca de Hong Kong y de la
China continental, tres cuartas
partes de la población local
pertenecen a etnias chinas.
Por eso el idioma mandarín se habla
ampliamente además del inglés,
con lo que las barreras lingüísticas
y culturales son muy pequeñas.
Asimismo, Singapur cuenta con algunas de las
mejores escuelas y universidades de todo el
mundo. Este es un factor particularmente
valorado por las familias chinas.
Por supuesto, la ciudad tiene una industria
de gestión de patrimonios muy desarrollada.
Y Para colmo, la gran presencia de empresas chinas
en el país está permitiendo tejer
todo un clúster de negocios chinos.)
Sin ir más lejos, ByteDance, que es la empresa
china propietaria de la popular aplicación TikTok,
tiene una importante oficina en Singapur
y ha estado apostando por incrementar
su peso hasta convertirla prácticamente
en una especie de segunda sede central.
(ByteDance, la propietaria de TikTok,
invertirá miles de millones en
Singapur a lo largo de tres años.
Planea invertir miles de millones de dólares
y contratar a cientos de empleados en Singapur
después de optar por establecer allí su sede
regional en el Sudeste Asiático. [...] Reuters)
Este es solo un ejemplo de decenas y
decenas que podríamos poner sobre la mesa.
Porque lo cierto es que Singapur se está
convirtiendo también en un gran polo
de empresas tecnológicas, especialmente
para aquellas orientadas a las finanzas.
Y es que, claro, está ciudad tiene
infraestructuras tecnológicas de primera,
un sistema educativo top y muy orientado
a las tecnologías de la información,
una regulación no demasiado densa y
un montón de empresas financieras.
Es decir, que aquí las Fintechs
se mueven como pez en el agua.
De hecho, este es quizás uno de los sectores
más pujantes en Singapur, pero no es el único.
¿Queréis saber cómo se está planteando el futuro
de la economía singapurense para esta especie de
segunda juventud que está experimentando
la economía local? ¿Queréis saber cómo
Singapur aspira a convertirse
en el país más rico del mundo?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (EL SINGAPUR QUE VIENE)
Últimamente, Singapur está que lo parte, y su gran
crecimiento como centro financiero y como refugio
para grandes patrimonios está haciendo que el
gobierno pueda plantearse nuevas metas económicas.
Por ejemplo, a finales del pasado año 2022
se estableció la estrategia hasta el 2030.
Y ¿en qué quiere convertirse
exactamente Singapur? Pues veréis,
partimos de la base de que algunos de los
sectores más desarrollados en el país son
actualmente el de las fintechs, la
biotecnología y el turismo médico.
(Para que os hagáis una idea, de las 100 empresas
locales con mayor crecimiento entre 2018 y 2021,
10 son fintech, ocho son de logística y transporte
y siete de energía y servicios públicos.
De hecho, solo en Singapur había registradas
1.002 fintechs en junio de 2022.)
Aunque puede que no sepáis a bote
pronto si esto es mucho o poco.
Pues veréis, si lo comparamos con las menos
de 10.000 que hay en Estados Unidos - y ojo,
que es el líder mundial - rápidamente nos damos
cuenta de que son muchísimas. Estados Unidos, el
líder mundial en este campo, tiene solo 10 veces
más Fintech, pese a tener 59 veces más habitantes.
Pero… No solo hablamos del mundo digital.
¿Y si os dijera que uno de los sectores
que más está creciendo últimamente
en este micropaís es, precisamente,
el de las manufacturas? ¿Y si además te dijera que
este sector es la gran prioridad del plan 2030?
Pues sí, a pesar de que Singapur es un sitio
muy pequeño, el sector manufacturero, esto es,
la industria de toda la vida, supone el 22 % de
su PIB. Para que os hagáis una idea, en España,
Francia y Reino Unido su peso viene a ser
del 13, el 10 y el 9% respectivamente.
De hecho, uno de cada ocho empleos de Singapur
está precisamente en las manufacturas.
Como veis, no todo son grandes rascacielos de
bancos y aseguradoras. En Singapur hay mucho
más. Ahora bien, si estáis pensando
en fábricas de zapatos o de juguetes,
ya se os puede ir quitando eso de la cabeza.
(Singapur está especializada en un
tipo de manufactura muy avanzada
y de alto valor añadido, como la electrónica.
Esto incluye los semiconductores, la ingeniería
de precisión, los productos químicos y también
la producción de componentes para
la industria aeroespacial. En total,
las industrias avanzadas suponen en
torno al 80% de toda la producción.)
Igual que Suiza ha conseguido crear una
industria altamente especializada y sofisticada,
como por ejemplo la biomédica, en Singapur
están consiguiendo exactamente lo mismo.
Pero ahora el gobierno pretende ir más allá,
y para eso ha creado un plan en el que la
robótica y la inteligencia artificial juegan
un papel fundamental. El objetivo es que con
el tiempo los empleos locales de bajo valor
añadido se reduzcan al mínimo indispensable.
(La idea no solo es que los empleos de bajo
valor añadido se reduzcan en número, sino
que quienes los ocupen se trasladen diariamente
desde el fronterizo Estado malasio de Johor.
Y lo cierto es que van por el buen camino.
Para que os hagáis una idea,
en el quinquenio 2017-2021 la
productividad laboral manufacturera
creció una media del 11,9 % al año.)
Ahora bien, ¿por qué creen en Singapur que
tienen que reforzar las manufacturas en lugar
de especializar completamente
en el sector servicios a tope?
Pues veréis, al igual que hicieron los suizos,
en vez de descartar cualquier tipo de apuesta
por todo aquello que está más allá de bancos,
las aseguradoras y la industria de la
inversión, el gobierno quiere promover
una industria local fuerte que no esté tan
expuesta a los vaivenes económicos globales.
Es decir, la diversificación de toda la vida.
Eso sí, en campos de altísimo valor añadido.
Ya os contamos también aquí, en VisualPolitik,
cómo Singapur está haciendo algo parecido con el
sector primario. El gobierno está impulsando la
creación de granjas hi-tech por todo el país.
Os dejamos también el vídeo en la descripción.
Para lograrlo, Singapur cuenta aparentemente
con todos los ingredientes necesarios:
Una enorme cantidad de profesionales altamente
cualificados, una enorme cantidad de capital
listo para invertir en todo tipo de proyectos,
mucha seguridad jurídica, impuestos comedidos,
infraestructuras y comunicaciones top y una
larga lista de profesionales e inversores
deseosos de trasladarse a este lugar.
Así que, ya lo veis, Singapur parece
estar a punto de convertirse en la nueva
Suiza con una receta de éxito muy parecida,
aunque eso sí, actualizada a los nuevos
tiempos y a su contexto regional. Como veis,
los suizos todavía son más ricos…
Pero eso puede cambiar muy pronto.
Pero ahora… Turno para ti, ¿crees que
el modelo de Singapur para atrapar
grandes patrimonios es replicable en otros países?
Dejadnos vuestra opinión aquí abajo, en los
comentarios. Y, si os ha gustado este vídeo,
no olvidéis darle like y suscribiros a nuestro
canal para no perderos ninguna novedad.
Y recordad, no olvidéis echarle un vistazo a
NotNews.com y si os gusta lo que hacemos
podéis apoyarnos para seguir creando más
y mejores contenidos uniéndonos a nuestra
comunidad en Patreon. A cambio recibiréis
un montón de contenido extra. Os dejamos
el enlace aquí abajo, en la descripción.
Una vez más, gracias por estar
ahí. Un saludo y hasta la próxima.